in today's law vegas now eric palacios  from eric palacios and associates the  sponsors of this next segment explains  what are some of the penalties if you  get a dui  [Music]  i'm eric palacios welcome to the legal  minute this week's question is what are  the penalties for a dui there are six  main penalties first two days to six  months in jail  second 24 to 96 hours of community  service  third dui school fourth fines between  four hundred to one thousand dollars  fifth you have to attend a victim impact  panel and finally sixth your license may  be suspended for 185 days  in today's world with uber and lyft  there's no reason to drive under the  influence we'll see you next week here  on the legal minute  for more information give eric palacios  and associates a call at 702-444-7777  las vegas now we'll be right back